Moon knight a new action adventure series
coming to disney plus a very famous marvel
character for many years mark
spector he was a mercenary he
was left for dead in the egyptian
desert and he now may or may not
be infused with powers from khonshu the moon
god or he might just be crazy this is what
disney plus is doing for the mcu it is growing
it is expanding it thank you thank you so much
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new marvel moon night video oscar isaac and marvel
just dropped a first look so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes when it does
premiere so be sure to subscribe to get those
my loki episode videos are gonna start posting
really soon too in the next week or so we're doing
a disney plus giveaway for memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
post all your theories about which marvel movies
moon knight will cross over into in the future the
whole idea is that all these marvel disney plus
series will cross over with the movies they set
up movies so i'll talk about which movies i think
this series will help set up during the video but
you've probably been seeing oscar isaac posting
all kinds of behind the scenes videos as they
get ready to start filming he's been posting
his fight scenes his training with ethan hawk
ethan hawk if you didn't know is playing the main
villain of moon knight i have some theories about
who that's going to be so i'll cover that in a
second but in the past couple of days the official
announcement they posted was to confirm that yes
of course oscar isaac is playing moon knight in
the mcu as if we didn't already know that i
think it's just because they're getting ready
to start filming episodes right now he doesn't
have any of his own social media accounts so
marvel posted this to their main account but it
was oscar isaac himself who drafted the post in
the caption read we are moon knight i'll explain
what that means in a second if you're a long time
fan of the character you probably know exactly
what's going on but in addition to the general
announcement he also posted a bunch of concept
art as part of this and a bunch of pages from the
all new all different moon knight run in marvel
comics those are important because they kind of
retell his origin story so they're good jumping
on points for people who are completely new to
the moon knight character so it makes sense why
marvel would be pulling from that story for the
moon night disney plus series i'll explain that
story line in a second because it connects it
to some of the other stuff they've done in the
marvel disney plus series like what happened on
the wandavision episodes and what's happening with
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness but marvel
always changes the comic book story just a little
bit when they're adapting stuff for the tv shows
and for the marvel movies so just expect the same
treatment it won't be exactly like the comic book
run but if you have no idea who moonite is some
people refer to him as marvel's version of batman
i'll explain why that is he's not really their
version of batman that's an oversimplification
it'll make more sense when you understand how his
multiple personalities work and how he's presented
in stories but moon knight is generally one of
marvel's darker characters as kevin feige jokes
in that teaser video at the beginning of this he
draws his power from the egyptian moon god khonshu
or he might just be crazy the truth is that he's
both he suffers from dissociative personality
disorder he has three main personalities
that we'll probably see on the tv show
his real name is mark spector but his first
alternate personality is called steve grant
that's his millionaire playboy personality usually
you find him out on the town throwing his money
around funding charitable organizations going to
parties with the rich and famous of manhattan he
lives in the new york city area but his main role
is to basically fund all of mark spector's actions
as moon knight because he creates a lot of his own
technology that he uses his second personality is
jake lockley he's this very unassuming cab driver
who's kind of violent but who he uses mostly to
gather information that he couldn't otherwise get
is this really high profile millionaire playboy
persona but then there's the other mr knight
persona who's a relatively newer addition to
the moon knight story the mr knight version of the
character works inside the confines of law is less
quick to violence it is much more willing to work
with police than the other personas so he's sort
of a more balanced version of the character but
just general origin story for the character so he
started out as the rebellious son of this jewish
rabbi then he became a heavyweight boxer then a
us marine who fought in combat the more modern
retellings of his origin story sort of changed
which conflicts which wars that he fought in just
to move the timeline up but eventually he leaves
the marines to become a straight-up mercenary and
earn this fortune so that's where all of his money
comes from so he's super rich but he earned all
of it doing this super shady stuff as a mercenary
but it's during his time as a mercenary that
he winds up meeting a man called frenchy who
becomes sort of his version of whistler to make a
blade reference so his origin story is moon knight
actually begins on one of these random mercenary
missions that he's doing for a person called raul
bushman who's hired him to help him erade these
precious artifacts from an egyptian archaeology
dig site the bushman character who hired him to
help steal all this stuff winds up killing the
lead archaeologist he has a daughter who's also
there called marlene that he tries to kill mark
spector stops him but in the process almost winds
up dying himself just as he's about to die the god
khonshu appears to him saying that he'll keep him
alive if he agrees to become his avatar on earth
so obviously mark specter agrees gains all of
his powers and abilities as moon knight and his
relationship with khonshu becomes a lot like black
panther's relationship with the panther goddess
boss a lot of people think that black panther's
power comes from the heart-shaped herb because of
the way the black panther movie portrayed it but
black panther all the black panthers actually get
their superpowers from the panther goddess maybe
they'll get into that during black panther to
sort of clarify that because they burned all the
heart-shaped herb during the first black panther
movie so how are you going to create another black
panther well you just clarify that they actually
get their powers from the panther goddess but
the different superpowers the khonshu grants to
moon knight are very similar to black panther's
abilities enhanced strength endurance speed a
healing factor the difference is though is that
because khonshu portrays himself as the moon god
moon knight's powers are tied to the phases of
the moon and depending on the phase his powers
are amplified even more so for example he's most
powerful when the moon is full and weakest during
a new moon or waning crescent as you see here in
this handy chart for those of you that don't know
the phases of the moon also because of his
multiple personalities disorder his mind is
more resistant to psychic attacks and he can use
those alternate personalities to increase his pain
tolerance during fights just metaphorically
jumping from one personality to another
and while all this is going on khonshu will appear
to him in visions give him visions of other things
that come off like hallucinations playing into
the way that he seems mentally unstable sometimes
and he himself questions whether or not what
he's experiencing is actually real but like the
other avengers like black panther he uses a lot of
technology to enhance himself like black panther
he creates a lot of his own customized tech
vehicles aircraft all funded by the money that he
made while being a mercenary so after moon knight
accepts con shoes offer he frenchy and marlene go
back to america where he begins to act as moon
knight but in order to distance himself from his
passes mercenary in disguise's identity he creates
these three different personalities different
identities grant the millionaire playboy jake
the violent cab driver and then the moon knight
persona marlene eventually falls in love with him
becomes one of his confidants who knows his secret
identity and helps him in addition to frenchie
the way they explain his craziness his mental
deterioration is that he actually develops the
multiple personality disorder directly as a result
of trying to juggle all these different fake
personas so when he first becomes moon knight he's
just pretending to be all these other personas but
eventually becomes so complicated trying to juggle
all these different lives that he's leading
and he develops multiple personality disorder
the way iron man got around that back during the
first iron man movie is just to say you know what
this is way too complicated everybody i'm iron
man tony stark is iron man they're gonna also
play with that trope of the secret identity
in spider-man 3 no way home just because
mysterio doxed spider-man at the end of spider-man
far from home so everybody knows that peter parker
is spider-man but they have a funny way of playing
with that idea and whether or not people believe
it or whether people think that it's fake but
that's a whole other storyline during spider-man
3. so i'll talk about that when we get that
first big trailer but as the reader of moon
knight stories or when we're watching the episodes
of the moon knight series we're meant to question
whether or not he's pretending to be one of these
personas or if he's legitimately crazy and can't
control each of the personas like sometimes mark
spector will be watching news broadcast with
footage of moon knight fighting criminals from the
night before and he himself will question whether
or not this is all happening in his head like did
i just imagine that i was moon knight and that i
have this relationship with khonshu eventually we
actually learn more about khonshu's true origin
story as well so in that all new all different run
they sort of clarify that Khonshu is not actually
the egyptian god of the moon he's actually one of
the elder gods which will sound familiar like he's
way older than the actual egyptian gods so here's
our connection to wandavision one of the greatest
elder gods was C'thon i talked about him during
my wanda vision videos because they introduced
the darkhold during that series scarlet witch's
chaos magic and at least in the comics C'thon
is the god of chaos that's where chaos magic comes
from from him and he wrote the darkhold so khonshu
comes from the same pantheon that cathode comes
from he came into existence around the same time
but he himself khonshu does have parents that
are other elder gods that are more powerful
that'll also be important for what's happening
during this storyline that marvel's adapting or
it seems like they're adapting for the tv show and
the whole reason why khonshu chose mark spector as
his avatar on earth offered to save his life was
because of the way the old gods have lost some
of their power and influence in present day all
the elder gods are sort of trapped in this pocket
dimension called the overvoid and with the rise
of technology people around the world have stopped
believing in miracles as much most of the god's
power their influence on earth comes from the
prayers of their followers so as technology plays
a bigger role in people's lives they just stop
believing in all these crazy things that the gods
do for them and khonshu explains that mark spector
is actually very weak spirited his mind was
already nearly fractured so it was very easy for
him to manipulate mark spector into becoming his
avatar on earth and even though khonshu is kind of
nasty sometimes he's very selfish just like most
gods we'll see what gore the god butcher has to
say about that during thor love and thunder but
khonshu was actually trying to prevent some of
the other elder gods from his pantheon from
escaping that pocket dimension the overvoid
where they're trapped and taking over the main mcu
dimension and these other elder gods like seth his
father amon ra are doing the exact same thing that
khonshu did with mark spector they're manipulating
other characters in this storyline promising them
power and wealth if they'll become their avatars
on earth moon knight starts to see visions of
manhattan covered in sand with giant pyramids it
looks like it's becoming ancient egypt and it's
just meant to be a vision of what might come to
pass that these other elder gods are successful
and taking control of the main mcu dimension it's
very similar to what dormammu was doing in the
first doctor strange movie manipulating kaiselius
and the other followers to gain entry into the
main dimension so that he could take over absorb
it into the dark dimension moon knight was also a
member of the defenders in the past doctor strange
was a big defender's character for a long time
so all this multiverse alternate dimension elder
god stuff makes him a big doctor strange crossover
character but i don't expect to see him in doctor
strange too multiverse of madness but i do think
eventually he and doctor strange will share a
crossover story also because he's something of
a supernatural based character in the mcu he's
a prime crossover candidate for projects like
the new marvel blade movie in any other darker
mcu supernatural series or movies that they wind
up doing as for ethan hawk's villain character
right now just based on the fact that they seem
like they're adapting the all-new all different
moon knight story based on all the stuff that
oscar isaac is posting here to the marvel account
the best theory is that he's actually playing the
main villain of that arc who's called sun king
he's like a version of moon knight but he gets his
power from khonshu's father amon ra the god who
the egyptians worshiped as the sun god but who's
really just another more powerful elder god in
their pantheon so his character is just another
regular human like mark spector who's also kind
of crazy to begin with who also became amun ra's
avatar on earth and gained special powers just
like moon knight did when he became conscious
avatar so marvel phase four rolling very hard
in the multiverse trope like we have the loki
series that's coming up very multiverse based
series makes sense that moon knight is also kind
of a multiverse type of character because of his
relationship with konshu in the way khonshu exists
within the mcu right now they haven't said whether
or not they have a plan for moon knight season 2
they've only confirmed that loki in the what if
series are going to get season twos but they did
say a long time ago that some of the marvel disney
plus series will get multiple seasons they're
just waiting to announce which ones will until
each of them premiere in the next few years but
everyone post all your reactions to oscar isaac as
moon knight in the mcu i feel like he's going to
crush this it's going to be really cool and let me
know which other marvel movies you want to see him
cross over with in the future right now the series
is supposed to premiere sometime next spring maybe
early summer like around this time next year i
think there's a lot of evidence that we're gonna
get that spider-man 3 no way home trailer sometime
in the next week or so so of course i'll do a
video for that when it posts but leave all your
video requests in the comments below and i'll name
a giveaway winner when i post my next marvel video
no surprise there are a lot of spider-man 3
rumors flying around about sinister 6 stuff
so also do a video about that in the next couple
of days too because there are a lot of rumors
about big characters coming back from the tobey
maguire movies i just did a big video about kit
harington's black knight character in the eternals
trailer and his future in the avengers movies
you can click here to watch that and click here
for my brand new loki episode 1 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!